so you're thinking about running for
president in 2016
who isn't come on you'd make a good
candidate but can you talk like one
lucky for you we at aj+ have devised
this handy guide to helping you speak
campaign ease number one talk simply
leave the vocabulary at the library okay
don't flaunt your education after all
you don't need to know how to spell
governament to run it the purpose of the
military's kill people and break things
I never took a position on Keystone
until I took a position on Keystone
after we seal the borders after we turn
off the spigot that dispenses all the
goodies how he described his brain
surgery to his patients mrs. Levine
we're gonna go in there and her to the
spigot that's making your brain goodies
go boy number two be the only one in the
beginning God made the heavens and then
he skipped earth and made planet you if
you want to set yourself apart from
other candidates you've got to remind
America you're the only one that did
that thing you may or may not have done
I am the only candidate on this stage
who has never supported amnesty I'm the
only one on the stage who actually has a
five-year budget Jen everybody has an
only guy I'm the only guy this I'm the
only guy that let me tell you one thing
that I am the only guy I am the only guy
who had a tail as a child nicknamed
Jefferson that I used to color purple
until my daddy said I had to remove it
and now it's my toothbrush holder number
three be an outdoor cat politics haven't
tamed you you're an outsider wash Eng
tun what's that laundry by the pound as
a serious presidential candidate have as
little relevant experience possible
another political outsider I'm running
for
and I'm very much outside the box I am a
Republican in New Jersey I wake up every
morning as an outsider I don't even know
who I am when I look in the mirror who
was that lady next to me I am a dog even
if you're a former first lady senator
and cabinet member
you too are apparently an outsider well
I can't think of anything more of an
outsider than electing the first woman
president really he'll if Washington
were a Russian doll you'd be like the
little tiniest one at the very center of
it it's so warm in there
actually for centuries presidential
hopefuls have wanted to be seen as
Outsiders abraham lincoln and ulysses s
grant both painted themselves as regular
old joes when they weren't and Jimmy
Carter boasted more about being a peanut
farmer than a former state senator and
governor now we know why politicians
today lead their ads with I'm Joni Ernst
I grew up castrating hogs on an Iowa
farm and she won number four blamed the
media run out of words it's the media's
fault like Ted Cruz when he was asked
about his opposition to the budget deal
the questions that have been asked so
far in this debate illustrate why the
American people don't trust the media
then draw up a list of demands two
networks for future debates which is
actually what some GOP campaigns are now
doing demanding no lightning rounds no
candidate to candidate questions no
raising hands and that the temperature
be set to no higher than 67 degrees any
warmer and Marco Rubio and Jeb Bush
start singing pitbull it's weird
so you have your work cut out for you
and they make it look so easy
Hillary versus Bernie the
mayweather-pacquiao of politics and a
distraction that helps us momentarily
forget the other side is still undecided
on science